and I went to visit my husband you mean
your ex-husband is there any such thing
as like the perfect couple I think it
just depends on what your idea of
perfection is you know I think that um
it shouldn't be an ethereal thing that
you can't reach I think everyone's
version of perfect is different you know
what makes John perfect for you know you
ago that he is my perfect man
you know he's funny and warm and bright
and confident sort of a very involving
person to be around is he's enjoying
being a big sister she loves it yeah it
she's so sweet with her because
sometimes it could go either way
oh we where we are relieved that she has
yet to try and suffocate violet yeah Oh
tell me this what is the one thing that
John does that helps you out so much
makes him such a great dad oh my
goodness he's going to be the father in
my kid's life that that can do anything
for them I mean he's like so much more
adventurous than me like froze hazel on
the back of a bike and they take off
somewhere and go on some crazy [ __ ]
he's so hands-on so committed
you